good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a splendid gorgeous
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious day
speaking of
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
girlies hey girl how you doing that's a
lot of words I'm good that's it that's
one word that's one word such a snitch
answer yeah how are you good
laughs
literally that's that's like such a dead
end in podcasting it's giving Hugh Grant
good yeah it is it is that's my energy
today no I am doing very well thank you
I'm a little jealous because I heard
that you guys are having a snow day and
I see you're wearing Moon boots and
that's just like a Vibe I would kill for
I know
um it's actually not like a vibey snow
day if that makes you feel any better
one because it's a Tuesday so like you
know two it's like flurries it's like
half rain half snow so it's not sticking
the floor like the streets are just wet
it's not like a gorgeous white
Christmasy Vibe there's really not much
for you to feel fomo about that's really
sweet thanks turdy Lou you always know
how to cheer me up and you know how I
feel about the snow in New York it's
Heavenly for about 15 minutes and then
it's weeks and weeks of hard Brown snow
on every corner oh you're gonna slip and
hurt yourself like it's it's not all
it's cracked up to be in the movies
not a lot of things aren't
so true what else
um I actually had two stories I wanted
to share from Lisbon yesterday that I
forgot to share the first being that I
can't believe I didn't even like come on
here and tell everyone I was literally
hit by a car
right no but right you said I was
literally hit by a car yeah yeah
that right was like yeah sure yeah I saw
your story I was hit by a car because
you know one of my favorite things about
traveling abroad and just not even
abroad like other cities is they all
have that scooter thing you know lime
and bird it's such a fabulous way to get
around town I've done it in Austin I did
it in Rome in Rome I'm telling you I saw
the whole city in one day like it's so
fast to get around it's really great so
when they had it in Lisbon I was so
excited and we ended up in this like
really busy part of town having lunch
and there was so much traffic we're like
Okay so let's bird back to
the hotel it'll be like fun and it'll be
a great way to see more of the city but
Lisbon is like not the type of town
built for birds like they really
shouldn't have them there it's so hilly
like the craziest inclines so all four
of us me Margo Emily and Ben are
scootering we're getting up this
Cobblestone Hill me and Ben like our
scooters stop halfway because like
honestly we way too much like it
couldn't do it Margo and Emily like make
it all the way to the top we're halfway
on this crazy Hill and we have to start
pushing our scooters Jackie I actually
cannot imagine
like a more hellish Endeavor it was
giving cardiac hell remember yeah when
Jackie and I went to Camp there was this
truly horrendous Hill like one of the
worst Hills ever and they called it
cardiac kill because walking up it would
literally put you into cardiac arrest
that's where I was but you know what I
didn't let that oh bless you
I didn't let that you know dissuade me
I'm like I'm still like yeah scooter
scooter and then we get to like City
Center where there's like trains and
cars and a Millions different Crossroads
and I'm like starting to panic because
there's really nowhere for us to scoot
so I'm like literally in the middle of
the street and cars are honking at me
and this car is coming up from behind me
and literally their rear view mirror
knocks into me like I thank God I wasn't
thrown off my scooter because it would
have been so much worse I caught myself
and thank God also that Emily saw it
because I know everyone else would have
been like you're so dramatic you're
wearing a hit by a car but I was
hit by a car and that was the time when
I'm like listen it's over I'm gonna get
a taxi I'm parking my bird here and then
it was like a No Parking Zone I could
have went it was horrible
but I just wanted everyone to know like
I was hit by a car and I lived to tell
the tale
and we're so glad that you could be with
us turdy Lou like I was spiced despite
your circumstances I didn't need to go
to the hospital but like one inch closer
hospital
I'm sure and then the other story that I
think you're going to find hilarious I
literally had forgotten about it until
this morning so we were out and Ben was
talking to a bunch of the guys about um
I think they were just talking about how
like Ben can't take a good picture you
know and one of Ben's like gripes with
this world is famousbirthdays.com that's
like that it's like a website that just
has like everyone's birthday on the
planet if you're like a z-lister you're
on there so Ben's like so upset about
the photo they use for his profile on
famousbirthdays.com on my way okay yeah
check it out I feel like you need
context too it's really old his eyes are
like half closed he's smiling like
seriously like a freak he looks
literally very good no this picture
oh maybe they changed it he looks very
good because the one that they used
forever was the um roast of Rob Lowe
picture from the red carpet okay so
whatever so Ben was telling this guy
about the photo and he wanted to show
the guy the photo that he was
referencing so Ben Googled
um
then Googled Ben Soffer celebrity
but can you listen to me I keep telling
stories you're seizing you're on your
phone you're on your iPad
suffer Rob Lowe roast it doesn't matter
just listen I am listening am I talking
to nobody then stop for celebrity I'm so
excited for what came up so Google's
Ben's off her celebrity and he finds the
photo that he needs and Ben was like
really drunk and he probably could have
just Googled Ben's offer but like he
wrote Benson for celebrity
and so
so
whatever the guy sees the picture and
they have a laugh about it but then like
an hour later Ben's talking to another
group of guys about how they really all
want to go to the Blink 182 concert at
USB arena in a few weeks no so Ben whips
out his phone to find the date and they
all see Ben Safari Ben saw for celebrity
as his most recent Google search these
guys been Jackie roasted Ben to filth
Ben got in bed he was so embarrassed he
was like I don't know why I Googled that
like I was drunk and I should have just
deleted it and then everyone saw it and
they thought I was Googling myself Ben
saw for a celebrity and I was like
listen
it's fine it's fine it's horrifying and
embarrassing and I'm so glad it wasn't
me but it's fine it's terrifying
obviously those people and Ben will not
be lifelong friends I hope they had a
good night together because that was it
for them no honestly if like that was me
like I would die I'm so like I I was
trying to make him feel better but like
between us I'm like that's really bad
that's really bad I didn't want to like
make him spiral more and become more
anxious but I was like that's so
embarrassing and then like when you're
when you're drunk and you just have even
more anxiety about like you know
something you did that was weird because
you're drunk yeah
that's it for celebrity Ben tougher
celebrity
now I feel like I have officially
recapped my trip to Lisbon but like when
I got off the show yesterday I couldn't
believe I forgot two of the best stories
from Lisbon I was literally hit by a car
and Ben might as well have been hit by a
car because it was so embarrassing he
was emotionally hit by a card I was
physically hit by a car Ben was
emotionally hit by a car exactly and I
found the roast of Rob Lowe picks it's
not the best of either of us honestly
that was my first actually ever red
carpet I talked about it in my book
because it was like such a big deal
um and I was so insecure like about
everything my face my body like I was
just like not a happy person physically
at that time
um and it was a dark day I actually wore
your dress yeah remember that dress and
like a Zara jacket Zara whatever it's
it's honestly like not terrible it's not
an embarrassing look like it's uh okay
not something about like ages horribly
okay thank you like really respectable
thank you thank you for saying that what
was your like first photographed moment
hmm actually I think I know what it is
and I'm not no no that doesn't count
um okay first like no when I like went
to something that was a red carpet and
had my picture taken yeah on a red
carpet
maybe Okay magazine
oh yeah that was like one of the worst
photos of me ever yeah
that's also part of my like saying yes
to life philosophies like I'm really
happy with the way I'm looking right now
like my face is sitting you gotta get
your pictures and get images I gotta get
my pictures taken so I can replace the
ones that exist out there
that's kind of like really if I'm being
totally transparent with our audience
the impetus behind saying yes to life I
think that that is as good a reason as
any thank you thank you for your support
yeah
um so it's Tuesday what is that what
does that mean to you it means that
we're just easing into this week we have
some fun stories nothing crazy we're not
going to change the world but we're
going to talk about a bunch of people
doing funny silly things who knows
Jackie we might change the world don't
say that yeah I think every day we
change the world in our own small way
Jackie that's beautiful and at least
we're not like destroying the world like
so many other entities like we're not
contributing to like the negativity and
yeah no but like we're not like you know
uh a bank that's on the verge to
collapse and can't give like right
hard-working people their money so true
unless we're not a bank
could be worse things than being a bank
I don't know I feel good about the
honest work that we do here 100 Jax 100
so that's enough for me now tell me
I was rolled
oh he he gave us hell last night he he
and I have a little cold both of us so
nothing like crazy but just enough to
make you uncomfortable and he was up a
lot in the night so we were up a lot in
the night but he seems great today like
he's
same old world so rolled like ruin
everyone's night wake up Sprite like
energy what's your breakfast everyone oh
that's pancakes hey guys get up it's
seven come on hey Mom what are you
making
what are you making for breakfast uh
well he did have pancake and I had Bagel
which he then wanted my day go I was
like no these kids like always taking
everything you have desperate for my
coffee I'm like yeah I'll leave it here
you could have it in 20 years imagine
Harry drinking coffee like so cute it's
also disgusting your coffee yeah because
I just have like Nespresso with half and
half
it tastes like coffee that's like a real
real coffee right but I know he liked my
little cup Kiara frodny X Nespresso and
how is LC number two I feel like we
haven't even spoken about in like the
baby in your belly totally that's so us
um good
you know just I'm so happy in my second
trimester it's so much
more pleasant than my first trimester I
have more energy been running some
errands been driving a little bit your
girl got her nails done if you're
watching on the YouTube I have a
manicure for the first time since
November shout out and am I like just
excited like I missed having a manicure
that like it looks that is 100 perfect
not chipped it's just one it's chipped
and I'll be like I miss having bare
nails that I didn't have to upkeep it's
just nice to look down at your hands and
like not feel ashamed yeah no and I've
got nice hands plus like with my
prenatals my nails are growing long and
strong and I just wanted to dress them
up since they're looking so gorgeous
because she's a girl with freedom she
can go where she pleases because she has
a license and a Tesla I have my Tesla
and I finally got my charger installed
for my Tesla oh good that was holding me
back a little bit even though exactly
did take it to get charged for me
um
so I had enough battery but it's like
now that I have my charger I am
completely set like first I got my
permit but I still need my license and I
had my license but I don't have a car
then I have a car but I need someone to
drive with me now and then I have a car
but it doesn't have battery so now it's
like I still would like when someone
drives with me but I need to
yeah now you just need a parent or
Guardian yeah I need a turdy you need
attorney well I have a a trip planned to
come see you a very quick trip at the
end of this month one day in and out
just enough time to kiss rolled
let Kayla yell at me
and let Levi watch the yelling the abuse
um and then I'm coming back a few days
later for a good amount of time so
Jackson Claude are going to be back
together again can't wait
can't wait to can't wait to drive you
around in my Tesla I can't wait to be a
passenger princess too and like being
like you know you've been quite a
distracted distracting passenger
princess for the many years I've driven
you around especially when I was younger
and not so confident I'm in the only car
accident I've ever gotten into was 100
your fault
um so I'm excited to be that for you
can't wait make content
choose the music and it's really fun
choosing the music in the Tesla it's
like a big iPad and just pull up Spotify
it's all there it looks like this app
like it's so amazing I'm so looking
forward to the relaxation of being in
the passenger seat well it's not like
that relaxing because you're still
driving with Moi yeah it's true very
tense Drive I feel like your shoulders
like up by your ears
yeah yeah it just depends
one second to a Groove it's good and I
have to know like where I'm going I I
always snap out my route you know no but
also having to adhere to a map while
you're still like not that comfortable
driving and like you take one second to
look to the GPS and you feel like in
front of you like everything's gonna
crash no I know but that's why like the
whole time that I'm driving I figure out
where which direction my next turn is
and I stay in that lane the whole time
of course of course of course unless
it's the left lane
oh do you not with the left lane
like not if I don't have to just because
I don't want to slow everyone down right
now and then people honk at you and cut
you off it's like embarrassing yeah no
it's just like I just I don't want to
draw attention to myself like I'm not
embarrassed that I'm driving the speed
limit like I'm really not you should be
you should not you should be
okay you don't drive below the speed
limit what do you drive below the speed
limit no okay
but I'd rather be with people who are
more my speed no like more you know like
like-minded individuals like-minded
individuals is there anything better no
no no
um so we've got a great great show for
you guys today and if that's all she
wrote then That's All She Wrote yeah so
without further I did it did it do here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know
and the best five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by Caraway
get a head start on spring cleaning with
Caraway their thoughtfully designed sets
and complementary storage make getting
and staying organized easier than ever
you can now save 10 on the full Suite of
Caraway products from their internet
famous cookware to their newly launched
launched food storage set so their high
quality ceramic coated kitchenware is
free of PTFE like Teflon it's free of
lead it's free of cadmium and other
toxic chemicals and their kitchenware
comes in a variety of chic Shades that
all include contemporary easy access
storage solutions so their naturally
slick surface means minimal oil or
butter for slide off the pan eggs and
easy cleaning there's so much about
Caraway to unpack like one the surface
oh my God no longer the days of like
scrubbing scrubbing getting literal
carpal tunnel just to get the eggs off
the pan they clean so easily they work
really well they're really beautiful so
it looks good in your kitchen not like
cluttered and gross and they're super
easy to storage if you don't have a ton
of storage space like in an apartment in
New York City uh there's not like draws
full of like mismatched pans and pots
and covers
so again it's non-toxic it's easy
cooking and it's well loved over 40 000
people have raved about their Caraway
kitchen so now it's time for you to try
it yourself I feel like whenever Jackie
is cooking on social media you'll see
her using her Caraway you know the once
a month I get in the kitchen I
exclusively use Caraway and I'm always
watching washing my Caraway because it's
in the sink every morning because Ben
only uses it like we have so many
different pants he only uses the Caraway
one I really should just toss my other
ones
so visit carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10 off your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 or use code
toast 10 at checkout Caraway non-toxic
cookware made Modern today's episode is
also brought to you by Thrive Market our
go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting it all quickly shipped to our
doorstep is a huge Time Saver so if you
become a Thrive Market member you can
save money on every single order on
average Jack and I are saving over 30
percent each time getting that big
Thrive Market box to your house once a
week once every two weeks it's nothing
better what are some of your favorite
items you've discovered because they
have really good they have the stuff you
know and it's really easy to discover
new brands too yeah they also have
Thrive Market branded things so for all
of my like cooking needs and cooking
supplies like I use their olive oil
spray avocado spray
um their granola like they have they
make their own products too and like
it's just so great it's a marketplace
with clean food so really any thing that
you want to get there you don't have to
do the vetting you have to walk through
the grocery store and look at all the
ingredients like if it's on Thrive
Market it is
oh sorry market approved Thrive Market
approved yeah and so the filters on
their website save you a lot of time
because whether you're looking for like
gluten-free snacks non-toxic cleaning
Essentials you can curate your own
shopping experience with just the click
of a button and when you join Thrive
Market you're also helping a family in
need their one for one membership
matching program basically you join and
Thrive Market gives so join Thrive
market today and get 30 off your first
order plus a free 60 gift go to
thrivemarket.com the toast for 30 off
your first order plus a free 60 gift
that's
t-h-r-i-v-e market.com slash the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast thank you
turdy Lou you're welcome first story
Little Romance news becoming a little
more legit
Kendall Jenner and Bad Bunny dating
rumors are heating up as they left the
Oscars bash together oh I didn't see
this I saw they went for sushi with a
group yeah there was some group activity
but now Kendall and Bad Bunny were seen
leaving Beyonce and Jay-Z's 2023 Oscars
after party together on Sunday night
further fueling rumors that they are
romantically involved it's unclear if
they arrived together but they were
photographed skedaddling from the Soiree
in the same vehicle at the end of the
evening while she attempted to cover her
face with her hand to avoid the
paparazzi he seemed a little more
relaxed around the cameras earlier in
the evening she went to vanity fairs
annual Oscars bash alongside Haley
Bieber and her sister Kylie then it
seemed like they were going to an after
party there was an outfit change and
they call Kendall from the party bus and
they're like we're here come out so I
think she went with them still to this
Beyonce Jay-Z party and then left with
Mr Bunny by the way I'm really obsessed
with this pairing like the more photos I
see of them together the more I really
like think about how they're so
perfectly matched from you know Fame to
looks and I feel like they actually not
that I literally know either of them on
a personal level but I feel like their
personalities would vibe too because
she's like chill cool girl I like to
drink beer I'm kind of weird and nerdy
and like I I see them being a match I
really do and I I think this is great
I've said it once I've said it again
like the family needs something fresh
they need something right now and I
think this could be it especially like
what if they go to like the Met Gala
together
obsessed if they go to the Met Gala
together I really like them as a couple
and I do feel like if you're leaving an
after party together in the wee hours
yeah alone like you're hooking up no for
sure and this is like keep in mind you
know sharing a cluster no but after a
few dates so it's not just like there
met at the party and like they're gonna
you know blank tonight but it's like
there's a relationship that's brewing
and keep in mind you know sharing a car
for us mere mortals is a method of
convenience but these people have a
surplus of everything drivers cars so
it's a it's a specific thing to share
that means you're going to the same
place yeah no and Kylie had a bus for
them she could have gotten back on the
bus and she didn't no like there were so
many options for her in terms of
Transportation but she chose to drive
with Bad Bunny and I'm choosing to
believe that that means something it
does mean something and it means
something really good and hopeful for
all of us yeah I like this you know for
Kendall I really thought like we were
not gonna see her like dating anymore
because I really thought her and Devin
Booker were OTP and while I am still
grieving the loss of that relationship I
kind of love like single Kenny like I
kind of forgot how before because she
was with Devin for a while like she
really is like this Bachelorette like
this gal about town she's you know the
it girl of fashion but she's also on
reality TV and she just is like she's
kind of everything of the sort so you
know she dated Harry Styles like she
really couldn't can date whoever she
want something bad bunny is very much
like upper echelon of like eligible
bachelors and Kendall's just out here
like pulling guys like this like Bad
Bunny and Harry Styles and like it's fun
to watch you know as a as a mortal yeah
but in the words of Kendall it's none of
your business where I throw this
Kendall said that yeah he didn't
remember that that tweet throw this
yeah that's what she said no by
the way that would have been like a fake
tweet no Claudia no someone was like
there was a story about how Kendall had
dated like a couple NBA players
and someone like commented on it nastily
uh of course about how she's being
passed around by NBA players oh she said
they act like I'm not in full control of
where I throw this cooch
okay by the way that's like my new
response to everything like when
everyone's like oh Ariana's epic it's
littering on your business where I throw
this couch like that's that's literally
gonna be my go-to I think I'm gonna
change my Instagram bio but I like
better no offense I don't like the word
no uh akucha makes it a little more
a little less
pornographic yeah you know but I like
love we've had this conversation I love
the word not in the way that like
people in porn I don't and I wish I knew
it was cooch that way I didn't have to
have said it
oh I like the word like I think
it's like so sweet but we had this
conversation like three years ago on the
toast and the morning toast back then
and people were like not agreeing but
like we just grew up in a house where
the word was like a cute word for
vagina like you know yeah and like
there's been like sort of like she's
talked about this tweet before I think
because I think people thought that like
maybe Chloe wrote it for her or
something she was like no and the
sisters that is something Chloe would
say Kendall wrote that herself that's
the thing look I feel like we don't
really know Kendall yeah because that's
a crazy thing to say from the girl that
like we thought was just very chill
right you know kind of nerdy not like
other girls yeah
maybe she isn't like other girls
sounds like she might not be actually
not in an ironic way but like in an
actual way so it's just a good reminder
that she is in control of where she
throws that cooch and perhaps the other
night it was thrown in the direction of
Bad Bunny and if it is even though it's
none of our business I just want to know
I support it I support it 100 percent
and it's just like the lesson from
today's show is like let's all be in
control of where we throw our coach you
know yeah
take take take that you know be in
control I love that
are you ready for our next story
um swallow me drip down inside of me
quick jump up for you let it get inside
of me okay remember our next story which
is a twofer of X run-ins potential
x-runnings at the Oscars I'm obsessed
with this obsessed obsessed first Austin
Butler and Vanessa Hudgens have an
awkward run-in at the Oscars after party
so unfortunate for Vanessa like really
could the timing could not have been
worse for for her like the universe
wanted wanted to ruin her night yeah the
actress was caught on video looking down
at her phone seemingly in an attempt to
avoid eye contact with her ex as she
walked past him Austin Butler at the
Vanity Fair Oscars party
at the time he was standing next to
Sharon Stone waiting for a car outside
the Swanky event so he's standing on the
curb with Sharon Stone and they're both
tall people already and Vanessa are
mini queen is walking in front of them
but I think she's on the street so she's
like already short and now she's shorter
before she's about to cross in front of
them she sees that it's Austin so she's
looking at her phone he doesn't see her
until she's passed and then he sees what
had happened he's like
yeah and it's just so unfortunate
because like the area in which they were
was actually enclosed but Sharon and
Austin Butler just happened to be
standing in like this open area where
the paparazzi across the street were
filming and taking photos so not only do
we get a film interaction of this like
entire Awkward Moment there's also now
paparazzi photos of like literally
Vanessa b-lining across standing
directly in front of Austin Butler and
ignoring him like it's so unfortunate
like it's it's horrible yeah but it's
inevitable question
literally no but it is like it and it's
so crazy how when you date someone in
the business like you're gonna see them
around and it's just wild that they were
together for 10 years it's not like it's
not nothing any old ex it's literally
like an ex-husband yeah no and like when
he first got cass's Elvis like it
appeared as though they were on decent
terms like she was on Kelly and Ryan
saying like I've always wanted this for
him he had actually like credited her
being like it was actually her idea like
so it seemed like they were still
supporting one another and then slowly
but surely like that stopped and then
Vanessa recently commented on that Meme
like making fun of Austin's voice so
it's clear that there there is bad blood
yeah well at first I thought maybe it
was amicable no there's totally bad
blood and she's engaged now so that's
good for her she walked by with a ring
on her finger yeah he's with Kaya Gerber
also good for him it's just
awkward no matter how you slice it no I
know and it's like
I'm happy for Vanessa that like at least
she's like keeping up with him like he
really left her and like ascended to
fame like he was a Disney star the
Carrie diary oh sorry Nickelodeon The
Carrie Diaries when they were together
and then right when they broke up it's
like when he became this big star of the
Oscars and like you know I'm glad she's
at the Oscars too like oh you thought
you could ditch me and go to the Oscars
I'm here too on my own yeah like
good for her at least we have that yeah
well Part B to this story someone who
wasn't in the mood to see an ex rumors
are that Tom Cruise missed the Oscars to
avoid seeing Nicole Kidman
yeah the Tom Cruise allegedly feels the
need to stay far away from his ex-wife
Nicole Kidman the Top Gun actor was
noticeably absent from the 2023 Oscars
on Sunday despite the movie being
nominated for six Awards and it really
being his movie he was reportedly M.I.A
because he wanted to avoid an awkward
run-in with Nicole whom he divorced more
than 20 years ago A source told the
Daily Mail that Tom was not there
because she was there and he did not
want a run-in but insiders other
insiders say that uh his absence was not
personal and instead the result of
scheduling issues what do we think well
I think if if true like it's entirely
possible like the Oscars
is Nicole Kidman's domain like she's
nominated all the time she's always in
that's being nominated he's like
really like not like I know he's a movie
star but he's not like an Oscar like guy
like that's her area you know like
that's her territory
was she nominated this year or in
anything that was nominated I don't know
but it doesn't matter like she's Queen
of the Oscars like she always goes yeah
she's been going for the last like 20
years
so I could see him like bowing out
there's like I feel like nobody even
really talks about their marriage like
there is so much there
clearly there's a lot there if he's
avoiding the Oscars because of her but I
just I don't know Tom Cruise at all I
don't know him from Adam you don't but I
feel like
he wouldn't let them back down stop him
yeah he's like it's his movie it was
really his year at the movies like
everybody's talking about Top Gun you
can't talk about Top Gun without Tom
Cruise
I don't think that he was gonna like be
shy and be like no it's awkward he's
also 60. I don't think 60 year olds get
awkward that is true and I do agree I
think personality wise I think what we
know about him like from Scientology
he's like he's like a beast like he
doesn't back down from a thing yeah he
does his own stunts he can't see his ex
on the carpet no that's totally fair and
totally a really good way of looking at
it he doesn't seem like the type of guy
to back down from like a potentially
uncomfortable like like if he wants to
do something he's Tom Cruise
like he gets it done you know he thinks
he's like toxic male yeah he's not like
skirting around Nicole Kidman 20 years
after their yeah divorce
is Tom Cruise single I was just
wondering that I he's publicly single
like he's not yeah publicly in a
relationship but he's got it like
I don't know what happens I mean I know
he's like rich and famous but I don't
know how anyone would want to be with
him like when you look at Katie Holmes
and Nicole Kidman like how they both ran
from him and like how
serious and like deadly their divorces
are he seems so toxic like the
Scientology of it all had Nicole's their
kids together Nicole and Tom's kids
don't talk to Nicole because she left
Scientology
yeah that's like that's but he
could date a Scientologist just yes he
could
I guess if you're into Scientology
that's like the most eligible bachelor
out there
that's like the Bad Bunny yeah yeah I
guess
can't relate it he's also like not cute
there's a lid for every pot turdy Lou oh
my God ain't that the truth I mean
Buster murder has a girlfriend so if
you're out there you know feeling like
there's no hope for you just know there
is yeah because that freak not only is
he like the weirdest looking
of all time but uh his
family uh he has a girlfriend so
keep going on those apps it's gonna
happen for you it is gonna happen for
you there's that's so true there's a
cover for every pot yeah caraway.com and
at Caraway it's not like one of those
pots where you can never find the cover
like mine it's just like so clear which
one's the right one so true between
caraway and Thrive market like you're
gonna have an amazing meal ugh I could
use an amazing meal what are you gonna
have for lunch today so I don't know
about lunch but I'm actually I was going
through my cookbooks to this morning
looking for a dinner recipe and what'd
you land on I haven't found something
that like looks like what I'm craving I
gotta get into another book I've
actually been thinking like today I'm
gonna switch up my lunch because I was
saying yesterday like I ate so poorly in
Lisbon I'm trying to have like actually
like nutritious meals and I feel like I
really need some roughage I still
haven't made a poo yeah um but I can't
really eat a salad like that's just not
how I was built but I'm thinking a wrap
wrap is so good what about a smoothie
it's such a good way to like shove
lettuce into things like I'll make a
smoothie and like I'll put so much
spinach in it but when you blend up
spinach it tastes like nothing it's like
green water and then you add all the
good flavors it's like oh my God I just
had three cups of spinach maybe yeah
maybe I'll think about it like I really
I think a wrap is a good place to start
for me yeah for lunch maybe a smoothie
for snack
maybe maybe it's like a little protein I
for you actually you get a lot of you
probably put more protein than me in
your day your chicken at every meal oh
yeah no I'm not my protein I'm good yeah
no protein's a concern for me I don't
use protein powder though roughage no I
don't know her
yeah maybe I'll I'll get into like a
half big harvest book because I wanna I
wanna do I've been feeling like I get so
many reels cooking videos and like
chicken is just not what I'm feeling
right now meat not at all but it's fine
tomato based not really either but like
you know a light salad like an orzo
salad you know what I mean I feel like
hbh has some good recipes I need to get
into it I need to do my research and
then that's gonna be my outing for the
day is going to get the ingredients for
my dinner because I'm trying to drive
every day that's good yeah that's good
that's really good thanks turdy Lou I'm
glad you approve yeah welcome
are you ready for our next story is it
our
what is it our third it's our third
yeah I'm ready Tyler Cameron revealed he
was only had 200 when he was dating Gigi
Hadid so this interview is going viral
because Tyler Cameron is talking about
one when he dated Gigi and I don't think
he's ever gone into such detail and two
he's talking about the financial aspects
of dating Gigi Hadid when he just came
off of a reality show right
the reality star enjoyed a brief
two-month romance with Gigi in 2019
shortly after his stint on The Bachelor
he appeared on Monday's episode of the
podcast trading secrets and he disclosed
his lack of finances at the time so
Jason said quote he goes to me dude I
don't know what the I'm doing I've
got five thousand dollars in my bank
account I don't know what my next job is
and I'm dating Gigi Hadid Tyler
corrected him and said not even five
thousand dollars I had like two hundred
dollars you know what I mean he said I'd
be going on dates like this is in my
early days of living in New York City
I'm living on Matt's bean bag I have no
money but I'm like the happiest I've
ever been because like the world is wide
open to me in New York City I can do
whatever I want he recalled calling his
dad from the bathroom to ask him for
money to pay for the date he was on I'd
be going on dates I'm like calling up
Pops in the bathroom I'm like Pops I
don't think my credit card's gonna go
through I need you to send me money
right now and he's so cute and he's like
you got it son so go get it oh
um
Jason asked when you want to date with
Gigi only of 200 to your name how do you
pay for it do you ever have a story like
how are you managing that Tyler
explained that you're just crossing your
fingers at this point at this point I
don't even know what a credit card is I
got a straight debit card so when you
hit zero you hit zero yeah you know I'm
just crossing my fingers hoping it
swipes and it just keeps swiping no
that's so funny I've often wondered
about the logistics of when Tyler was
dating Gigi but I'm not I'm less focused
on the financials of it all I'm so
curious about the funeral like that's to
me one of the great wonders of the world
it's like who what when where why how
did Tyler Cameron who was like literally
been on three dates with a girl ended up
flying to the Netherlands for her
grandma's funeral like
the questions just are endless yeah you
know they're both single right now sort
of
yeah wasn't Gigi was linked to Leo but
then Leo was linked to that child yeah
and then she went back home I think yeah
and then they were also and Leo they
keep saying they're at the same parties
but like everybody's at the same party
but there are only so many parties for
cool people yeah
yeah no I don't know if they're together
but they are still there are both single
right now but I feel like they weren't
Gigi and Tyler weren't like OTP it was
really like a moment in time flash in
the pan like you had to be there you
know yeah but what's also funny is like
she's obviously so successful he just
came off I'm sure she didn't know the
extent of his finances but it's like
she's still not paying for today no by
the way and you know what I respect that
about GG she's a woman who wants to be
taken care of like your financial
situation is irrelevant to me you're
paying for dinner like yeah that I am
truly on my way to becoming one of the
world's richest women oh you don't have
a pot to piss in or a bed to sleep in
let's go to Carbone figure it out yeah
no like we'll find a way we we stand you
know she's a traditional chivalrous
Queen yeah
um obviously Tyler's in a better
financial situation now which is you
know
good for him yeah and it's good that he
can look back on that time and just and
not like focus on you know the stress of
the finances of it all but really like
it makes sense that it was the happiest
time for him he was like on top of the
world he's dating Gigi like he's beloved
he's moving he's changed in an instant
the world really opened up to him like I
imagine it was so exciting and he was
just like ready to grab Life by the
balls right because before the show he
was like working in construction in
Florida like it lived a very happy
simple life and then within like a
couple of weeks he was a nationwide
Superstar like known by everyone and
then on top of that to not only come out
on top from the franchise but then to
get to take it to another level that
nobody had ever done before which is
like dating a celebrity not only a
celebrity like the world's biggest
supermodel
how could that not be the happiest Time
of Your Life yeah you know yeah
so just fun factoids from behind the
scenes Jason tartic is always getting
people to like open up about how much
money they have or had on his podcast I
did his podcast once you should check it
out it's a good episode I don't reveal
anything I'm not into this I'm not into
this whole culture like demanding
Financial transparency from everyone
like you want to be transparent about
what you make love that for you don't
ask me because I'm not
telling you yeah there are some
things that are just Timeless I think
talk not talking about money is one of
them I think there's times where it's
beneficial but like
it's not a prerequisite no there's times
where it's beneficial especially in like
really corporate environments where like
they don't allow you to talk about your
your salary so that you don't make more
like that's toxic I get that no but
that's not what p-bond Tick Tock are
demanding of others no that what people
are demanding in this culture is like
total Financial transparency about
everything especially for influencers
it's like girl mind your own
business yeah like just know I'm never
gonna tell you ever yeah ever because
you know what I'm gatekeeping sure
that's what they call it that's what
they call it no I'm saying that's what
they call it because you're not going to
help other women how's that going to
help anyone why is it my job to help
other women no but why would that help
another woman how does that help another
woman to let her know her worth I guess
no your worth is like it's safe for your
podcast or your worth is your listeners
not because you're one yeah no I just
like I like not to be like let's be
really honest it's gonna be probably one
of the most honest things I say like
when I get up every morning like I'm
looking out for me and only me like I
cannot bear the brunt of having to like
help other women you know no but I but
even if you could bear the bread like
that's just dishonest to say that
Claudia ashrae should share this
information because it would help other
women it wouldn't it it really really
wouldn't no and that's not to say like
let's say there was by the way I'm one
of those people who just I know I know
why does that happen to me only on this
show I heard it like it's someone's
messing with me I just want to clarify
like that's not to say like if there is
a what like if there is a person what's
with women there's a person who helped
me I helped them but I'm just not out
here helping for the sake of helping I'm
not that person no and it's like if you
go to like a dinner with like one to one
with influencers buying influencer and
they're like starting out like in that
situation you can be helpful like girl
you are not getting paid what you
deserve of course
I do that a lot like people right I find
people like are always asking me for
like advice and stuff but again I'm more
than happy to know what the public is
asking you to do on Tick Tock yeah no
the public is like you have to make a
video and tell everyone what you got
paid for every single thing and how much
you pay in time and that's going to help
women turdy Lou don't forget it right
and I don't I don't support women if I
don't do that well you know what maybe I
don't support women because I've met
some of you and you're the worst and
that's just like not what it takes to
support women but no no I've said this
once I'll say it again and I've kind of
been like really kind of refining my
thesis on the whole women supporting
women thing
um and I just think it's worth
mentioning like I support people
and it's worth mentioning that some of
the most vile human beings I've ever met
in my life were women I would say all of
them were
um so I'm not just going to be out here
blanket supporting women because like
because that includes those people right
what have you said about me
question mark
yeah
so I'm like always refining that thesis
about women sporting women it's changing
all the time you know just think about
your decent be a decent person period
right and then I will I'll do anything
for you yeah
you're not just gonna get my support and
my advice because you're a woman no that
doesn't mean anything to me yeah
yeah are you a good person
are you charitable are you kind are you
generous
question mark
are you ready for our next story
question mark if it's the next story
that's brought to you by Perfect bar
exclamation point
looking for approach that was
technically
if it's I think that was the question
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
perfect looking for a protein bar that
actually tastes good well look no
further than perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you've
been looking for no chalky artificial
aftertaste here they're made with
freshly ground nut butter organic honey
and 20 organic superfoods perfect bar
has a variety of products like protein
bars little snack size bars that are
also good and good for you you'll be
sure to find something you love my
favorite I've said many times dark
chocolate chip peanut butter a little
sea salt on there it's gorgeous I love
that you keep it in the fridge because
the chocolate gets like hard and cold
and it's really delicious
um they have a cookie dough texture it's
creamy it's full of flavor and they're
unlike any other bars out there the
snack size that they now come in is
great because they're packed with up to
six grams of protein and 150 calories so
a little goes a long way throw it in
your purse before a long day throw it in
your purse before you're traveling and
you'll always just have something to
keep you so you don't start getting like
hangry on the plane
um they're made with whole food
ingredients they contain no artificial
preservatives perfect bar is stored in
the fridge so you grab one after a
workout for a quick bite while you're
out shopping and you'll feel good about
what you're snacking on perfect bar
knows that it'll be Love At First Bite
so for a limited time offer they are
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
that's right free snacks listen up
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or your PayPal account all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today today's episode
is also brought to you by neutralfall 30
million women are impacted by weekend or
thinning hair if you're among them know
that you're not alone and that there's a
solution that you can trust to deliver
results millions of Americans experience
sitting bless you as she sneezed on it
it's true a lot of people experience
thinning hair for a lot of just for
different reasons I honestly never
really had an issue with this up until a
few months ago when I had like a change
in my diet which can really be the
trigger for
um shedding which is what I was
experiencing and neutralfault when I was
looking for something to take everyone I
know recommended neutral fall and I had
a really good experience with it it's a
number one dermatologist recommended
hair growth supplement it's clinically
shown to improve your hair growth the
thickness the visible scalp coverage and
it supports healthy hair growth from
within so it targets the five root
causes of thinning which can be stress
hormones environment nutrition and
metabolism and it does that through
whole body health over 3000 Top Doctors
and stylists recommend neutralfal as an
effective and high quality solution for
healthier hair
in a clinical study 86 of women reported
improved hair growth after six months so
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support the toast by going to
nutrifall.com enter promo code toast and
you will save 15 off your first month's
subscription it is their best offer
anywhere it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order so get that 15
off at nutrifall.com which is spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code toast
will get you 15 off and free shipping on
every order nutriful.com
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
next story Avril Lavigne tells a topless
woman to get the off the stage at
the Juno Awards Queen Avril Lavigne
smoothly handled a topless protester at
the 2023 Juno Awards Monday by telling
the woman to get the off the stage
the singer had been introducing per uh
performer AP Dylan during the Canadian
award show when the woman crashed the
stage with a message written on her back
save the green belt initially Avro
ignored the protester but then turned
around and swatted at her chest as she
said get the off and added one more
time get the off a male
security guard then escorted the woman
off the stage it wasn't made entirely
clear if or immediately clear if she was
kicked out of the venue entirely though
I would thought she would this evening's
hosts Marvel star simulu later comp and
um selling Sunset star yeah
later complimented the punk rocker for
handing those topless lady Like A
Champion ugh I just hate people
who do like this whether you're
doing it like just because you like to
do pranks or because you're protesting
something like I don't give a if
you are disturbing and being like a
public menace I hate you like I
always think about that YouTuber
um who's like I think it's
Italian he's like in Milan and his thing
is like he'll go to celebrities and pick
them up yeah yeah yeah oh my God I
hate that guy like I wish bad
things on him like I hate people
who do like this either for
attention she was clearly protesting
something and you know what I don't
care that's like that's what and
now I'm into I'm inclined to side with
whatever you're protesting no and now
I'm inclined to destroy the green belt
as opposed to saving it yeah I think
there's been a lot of recently like
climate protests that are so funny the
art stuff they're like throwing olive
oil on the Mona Lisa which they're all
protected and they don't wind up doing
any damage whatsoever and it's like what
do you do for your cause because now we
all just hate hate you perfectly said
like what did you do for your cause we
all just hate you and you know
what I hate your cause too and I'm so
impassioned by you being such a menace
that I'm gonna do everything in my power
to actively work against your cause like
I don't even care what your
cause is yeah I hate people like this
like remembering that girl it's
different because some people do it for
like a cause which I think is
counterintuitive and stupid but some
people just do it like for pranks like
that girl who literally hopped the stage
at the Chanel fashion show in Paris all
those years ago and like ggit literally
threw her off the stage I hate people
like that like to
I really just can't like I can't one
thing that'll never be me yeah no
pranking for prank's sake is also one of
my least favorite probably worse it's
probably worse really because I think it
depends on the prank like I think that
that Chanel Runway thing was like
annoying and stupid but like kind of
harmless harmless victimless yeah and
because it was handled so well it just
is like kind of like a funny anecdote
maybe if it you know they were chasing
around the stage it ruins the show
whatever could have gone another way
um but just praying for prank's sake
like I think is so stupid Beyond but
also pray like uh whatever this is
stunt protesting for your cause also
stupid no but also like it's an award
show like there are probably miners
there and you have your tits out like
stop right oh we didn't even talk about
the tits of it all and then like the
security guard has to get her off the
stage but she's like you can't touch her
right yeah no like so Claudia you have
to support women including this one
right right thus bringing me back to my
aforementioned thesis but this woman
doesn't support Avril so now what now
what do we do the girls are fighting
no I just hate like this and it's
it's so layered as to why it's
problematic like one just stop two like
you can't be naked in public I'm sorry
like we live in a civilized society this
is a music award show I'm sure there's
not a lot of kids there but there
probably is they don't even see your
tits okay stop
she is wearing pasties doesn't matter
I'm
I'm crazy I just Avril handed it like a
champ I will say the security guard was
very slow to react and then when he once
he got up there like he couldn't really
do much because she was naked so it was
like a tough position for him to be in
um but I definitely think it could have
been handled a little better yeah
yeah I'm just hope that Avril was able
to find solace in the arms of her
boyfriend Tyga hopefully that's all you
can hope for a girl can dream
are you ready for a fifth and final
story yeah we gotta have some Bravo news
in here yeah we have to it's been such a
big month for Bravo like and everybody
wants every scrap of an update and we
both found this interesting because you
sent me this clip ow
what oh my God I just knocked my
microphone into my chin oh my that hurts
so bad like really hard
I'm okay first the car and now this
charity you have to take care of
yourself I know I'm I'm bruised listen
to your body my body's saying
take a nap
always
Andy Cohen issues a PSA for the upcoming
Trump girls episode he said you won't
believe it Andy Cohen has issued a PSA
over this shocking upcoming episode of
Vanderpump worlds as the Fallout from
scandival continues to unravel he said
Bravo fans are not going to believe that
Wednesday's episode tomorrow has not
been edited since the news of the affair
came to light he said there's something
I want to say guys you're going to watch
Wednesday's episode you are going to
think that it was recut okay it was not
re-cut this is the episode he warned
that fans are going to be shocked to
hear a conversation between Raquel Lala
and Katie as he promised viewers that
the footage was not touched I watched it
on my sick bed Wednesdays the episode
that's going to air in two days now it's
tomorrow I watched it and I was like
people are going to think we did this or
move stuff up the conversations that go
on between Katie and Lala and Raquel are
not to be believed in light of what has
come out this is how it was going to be
shown which makes it all the more
shocking you won't believe it right I'm
curious what what it is and what we
would have thought if we didn't know
this like but when I heard this I was so
excited I actually am having like a
little viewing party tomorrow night all
my friends are coming over I'm like guys
we have to we have to watch oh my God
look at you well I just want to say one
thing yeah if I may because I I heard
this clip and then like a few hours
later I had this thought which is that
we saw this um preview for the episode
where Raquel says to Lala like well good
thing you don't have a man to bring
around that way like Raquel won't be
around with him but in this
moment you do have to remember that
Raquel just found out that Lala hooked
up with James while she was dating James
so I think there is a little bit of
resentment where it's like oh if you had
a man to bring around right now and I'm
single like you know uh just give you a
taste of your own medicine it's actually
so true Lala has actual like nerve to
say that given what she did to Ryan
villagers so just that one conversation
on its own like
a little bit I feel like Raquel is
pissed at Lala like you hooked up with
my boyfriend yeah if you had one you
better be your pants to bring
him around oh you know what you're so
right but if I will be shocked by the
conversation between the three of them
if anything about like Sandoval or
Schwartz is mentioned but when it comes
to the Lala thing it's like we can't
forget that Lala just admitted to
hooking up with James while Raquel was
dating him for years engaged to him and
like she still is like heartbroken over
the relationship and just like a mess
over it so like not to give her a pass
for saying anything but just that one
line like when you put in that context
and like I feel like she said it as a
way to get back at her do you know what
I mean no by the way you're 100 right I
totally forgot about that part because
it's layered and once you add the layers
it all kind of makes sense like she's
entitled to be a little but Andy
said there's a conversation not just
that one thing so you know I don't I
don't think that's what they're he's
referring to it has it has to mention
Sandoval like if that's what and he's
being so dramatic about yeah yeah
I can't wait like the way I've been so
reinvigorated like I I I get like I get
into bed every night and I put on Bravo
like I'm just like I'm always eating it
like watch Happens Live has been so good
because there's so much going on in real
time and the shows are so delayed and
it's just it's very exciting oh I did
watch summer house last night right I
figured you were gonna talk about it
let's hear what let's go tell you it's
really not good
um and Danny Pellegrino actually had
like a whole Twitter Thread about it and
shared it on my Instagram because it's
so right it's like we're at a place
where like a lot a lot of these people
on the show have been on the show for so
long and they have these established
Dynamics and they have friends and they
have people they hate and
they're no longer like playing pretend
with the people they hate like Amanda
and Lindsay don't get along Paige and
Lindsay don't get along and maybe a few
years ago that would have been a
storyline like why aren't we friends
like let's make up but like neither of
them care like they're just not friends
period And there's such a gap between
like the old people and the new people
like Gabby and Sam who are like in their
early 20s and young and fabulous and
like Kyle who's 40 like
he said Kyle is older than Jason Hoppy
and Bethany Frankel were when they had
their show Bethany getting married like
let's put that into perspective why
imagine if they were in the summer house
exactly that's what it is so it's just
like I don't know it's not giving the
way it needs to give I just feel like so
many people are checked out like Paige
and Sierra have literally done and said
nothing like they feel so checked out
it's not working the script Dynamic I
feel like they're hitting a place where
like Vanderpump Rules hit before all
this happened where it was like old
people young people we don't know what
to do and it felt like this huge
disconnect between the group
um the drama like I'm actually confused
like
like I don't get it and you know what
everyone and basically like Danielle
blew up Italian night because she said
she didn't trust Amanda and then like
Amanda started you know fighting with
Lindsay and Danielle and Danielle
started the whole thing and she just
kind of like watched everything burn
down and then she started screaming at
Carl for not defending Lindsay and like
you know what first of all stay out of
other people's business like she's so
mad this episode because like Lindsay
and Carl are out at a bar in Lindsay and
Carl are just like hugging and making
out all the whole time and she's like
what about me I'm like that's
weird you have a boyfriend you're 30
years old like get a grip yeah so she's
just like inserting herself and it's
clear like this is where the Divide is
starting to happen because we know
Lindsey and Daniel aren't friends
anymore so she's starting to like you
know talk to Paige and Sierra and Amanda
about how you know they're moving too
fast Carl and Lindsay and she's just
being like a really bad friend
no but she's so extreme it's like I
either need to be
this whole house with you or I'm gonna
talk about your relationship yeah
like oh oh I'm mad everyone needs to
know or like I'm riding for you I'm
gonna burn this house down with my love
for you like she's so extreme she's
honestly like a like a terrible reality
star because she's so inconsistent and
up until this point she has not had a
storyline about her everything up until
this point has revolved around her being
Lindsay's mouthpiece and like it's
actually getting annoying yeah
so this like two weeks ago was like not
a great episode and then this week was
not a great episode either I don't know
why Andrea is not a full-time cast
member I don't know why literally this
guy Chris who isn't you know the most
interesting person is the only single
guy in the house like it's so weird this
is a very weird season yeah I think I
feel like they need a shake up and
that's kind of what saved a summer house
the first time they like brought in all
these new people and I feel like unless
it's a show with like a magical cast
like the Jersey Shore that just like
keeps regenerating itself when you have
this sort of premise like you do need to
keep it fresh and the problem is is that
so many people are fan favorites because
you know them over the years and you
love them but they don't like give much
to the show because also it's like at
this point why do I want to ruin my
reputation they have too much to lose
they've all started businesses and it's
like I like being liked by the fans I
don't want to get in the mud a hundred
percent and like the thing with the
Jersey Shore which is a great example is
like there was so much drama because it
was every night back to back out all
night out all night new couples new
hookups and like they're trying to make
it seem like they're partying a lot but
like they go to the club and then they
put the time stamps like they got home
at 11 30. like they're really not it's
not like a summer share house party it's
not that but like they're pretending
like it is yeah but also like Jersey
Shore was is a really good formula you
know a summer share house with people
who are down to clown but they just hit
the lottery with the cast yeah it was
ever everyone was a star yeah and like
the interpersonal relationships like
that Ronnie and Sam you know took off
but like Mike was kind kind of always in
love with Sam and then we had like like
The Little Gym Snooki Vinnie and snooky
Holly and J Wow hooked up yeah and there
would always be those like underlying
things they were always friends and then
other people would like come in Roger
Gianni Roger it would always be like
oh you know but Paulie hooked up with
like it was just ripe yeah no it was I
could literally write a dissertation on
the beauty of Jersey Shore like it is
the perfect show yeah
and I'm honestly so grateful to have
been influenced by it in my youth
honestly I am who I am because of that
show
yeah and the people and the cast they
were all just like
so themselves so they had nothing to
lose nothing to lose even as the show
got bigger they still didn't have
anything to lose because they were so
rewarded for being themselves you know
yeah no nobody like stopped getting
involved in the drama because they all
started making a lot of money like if
anything the money encouraged them to be
even worse yeah it was such a good show
yeah no summer house is not a Jersey
Shore
it never will be addressed but also like
the Hamptons are also just like not like
that no it's true it's like more of a
classy Affair like you you don't act
that way no I mean people do but it's
somebody's not working and and at the
beginning of the season I was like oh
this is good but the longer we go like
this measly drama is like not enough to
sustain a whole plot and if somebody's
not working somebody's got to give yeah
I honestly feel like
and this is not a statement on on Amanda
because I really like her but I do feel
like it might be Kyle and Amanda's time
yeah I agree like they've been the
center of the show the whole time and
it's worked and now they're just at a
place where it's like they're married
they're focused on their business
they're really not Kyle like gets drunk
and says crazy things just so he's like
still a core part of the show not
because it's like a a true feeling but
it's like
he would be better suited to just like
act his age and and step into like an a
mentor sort of role it'd be better for
like I think his
self it'd be better for his business
it'd be better for the show and nobody
wants to watch like a 40 year old
no they say up till three in the morning
with a bunch of 21 questions it's so
weird actually really I really like the
new girls though I think they have a lot
of potential like Gabby's very funny for
sure but what's a bunch of great new
girls without great new guys thank you
thank you it's really weird it's bizarre
it shouldn't I know it's definitely
harder to cast funny interesting party
guys like girls are always just like
more is more but my God to give us one
new guy and take away those two I even
would have taken that mute Alex from
last year it's literally not that hard
it's not hard there's so many people who
want to be on TV there's especially like
in New York that are like fake
influencery they need a gay guy for sure
yeah and they need more single guys for
the girls yeah no it's really not that
hard like it's not no rocket science it
should always be like an equal
somewhat equal
you're equal four and four it's
literally like eleven to two
it's crazy weird
yeah and doesn't like Chris feel weird
being in that house with like a bunch of
girls like at least Kyle is married to
one but like no I think it's weird for
Kyle to be in the house with a bunch of
girls yeah Chris is like this is awesome
yeah
yeah it's not weird Fork I don't think
Kyle feels weird but I I find it weird
that he's there something's not working
that's that's that's my thesis of the
day okay cool cool I could see how that
is true
um that's our show
um
so much for listening to the toast the
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so Spotify iTunes Stitch or public
radio I got radiocast box all the places
maybe listen to podcast find us a
toasting the five star review about it
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for the big day
it's the big day bye love ya bye